the doj security fears were over Trump's
souvenirs they said it was the ultimate
crime to keep a framed cover of time
yeah the latest Bombshells to come from
the Mar-A-Lago documents reveal that
Donald Trump is definitely without a
shadow of a doubt Donald Trump
the doj filing released on Tuesday
included a photo of documents seized and
it turns out Trump had a frame to Time
Magazine cover of himself
if that's illegal someone better raid
Harold Ford's basement yeah
you think Harold hasn't framed a copy of
this for his home
yeah I know I did I have several of them
above my bed and one in the bathroom
anyway get that get that there's the
back there anyway that time cover was
from a 2019 issue detailing the
Democratic primary race with all the
challengers looking at Trump let's take
a moment to be glad that wasn't a
swimsuit issue
Trump framing that issue and keeping it
is what any of us would do yet the media
calls it a stunning detail Jesus in
other words we're back to where we've
always been we're the same silly
hilarious stuff that feeds the media's
Trump Obsession they're more obsessed
with him than Stormy Daniels ever was
the other bombshell to drop this week
that Trump loves to gossip apparently he
bragged he knew illicit details of
French president Emmanuel macron's love
life and that info came from
intelligence he'd been briefed on
but who wouldn't gossip about that after
all macron's wife was his old high
school teacher who's 25 years older than
him
so I guess she wasn't just banging the
erasers
Trace you've been covering the raids
it's happened what should be the media
focus on I'm confused Greg honestly I'm
confused are they looking for secret
documents or sacred documents because
every time Trump is on the cover of a
magazine you know to him yes that's a
sacred document and you look at all
those folders and you think are they all
filled with magazine covers because
that's what it could be remember when
Trump was accused of putting up phony
Time Magazine pictures and all his golf
clubs around the country and it turned
out you know it was kind of a big joke
that did that but the truth here is it's
come down to this bizarre thing two
weeks ago the Washington Post reports
that what is in the secret documents are
nuclear secrets right these are nuclear
things and they've kind of kind of
pulled away from that and now it seems
to be a battle over documents that Trump
just won't give back we don't know
what's in there he won't give them back
and the doj is pissed about that yeah I
think Michelle my theory is some mover
Packer threw all the crap into a box
mixed everything up because that's what
I would do you and it's like and uh
Trump's like ah whatever I'll get to it
when I get to it this is a such a he's
probably thinking this is such a boring
conversation like about documents I
don't really care and then this happens
well I was looking at this picture
that's there and I was zooming in and
trying to really study it and the one
thing I noticed is that all those top
secret things they are paper clipped on
do you see the paper because they're not
stable I would think stapling would be
so much more efficient because like if
you just paper clip them the thing could
come off by the way those top secret
cover pages you can order them from the
general Services Administration
so maybe they just ordered a bunch of
them took paper clips and put them on
stuff that I don't know I don't know if
this is a bombshell or not but yeah all
this stuff about the carpet and The Time
magazine covers it that's just it's true
to Tracy's point it went from like it
went from nuclear code secrets to
stunning detail my magazine cover by the
way I just want to show everybody that I
was on on a cover once
anchors Kaylee
take that Harold you were never on
anchors magazine I gave that to you I
know you did among many other things
Jamie don't know what that means he's a
very generous person
terrible what's wrong with me Jamie
it would be interesting if somebody had
Intel an Intel file on your sex life
because it would probably just be a
blank page ever since you're divorced
that's really true I was actually on the
cover of Anchorage magazine
it probably it probably would be blank
um wasn't there one wasn't there one of
the Time magazine covers that he saved I
actually respected this wasn't there one
where they said some negative stuff
about it yeah and he saved it which I
think is like super cool that he you
know I don't know I sometimes get
motivated by things that were a failure
like I have my marriage certificate up
in my office and um
I'm having a name blank uh Mark Marcone
macaron macaron uh yeah I feel like
Trump's saying he has inside information
uh macron's sex life and then I find out
she's 25 years older than him I feel
like without a file he probably cheated
on her
um
I don't know like a ton about it uh but
come on pretty cool that Trump was on
Time Magazine I just heard that next
month Biden is going to be on time's up
magazine
oh red meat red meat Heralds
he just threw a big slab of red meat at
you
look he could also you know be on the
cover of those magazine saying he that
they won I think again people got to get
back to elections are won if you put
forward great ideas now own this Trump
thing for one moment if someone if I
packed up and someone told me to pack
pack my things up and they packed them
up for me and I realized that I had
something with something because the
documents are not his Trace they belong
to they belong to us hold for one sec he
the when you're president United States
it won't say she one day but he is the
custodian of all those papers so keep
going
sexist might say you're you're a
custodian of all those papers not the
owner and even when you leave office you
don't get the possessment you do get
access to them for purpose of writing a
book and other things but if you didn't
know what was in the box and they told
you sir there are things in the box that
you should not have need to be returned
I'd return them I think most red blooded
honest Americans would just return them
because they're not they're not his now
if this turns out to be busy you get
your stuff I would be really cool
available to box in with Gwyneth
Paltrow's head but he was like
they have they they've asked I'm gonna
leave it alone but they've asked
multiple times it didn't turn it over
and you got to turn these things back
and it's not but the only I think the
equation we have is is Hillary Clinton
right you can do Hillary Clinton she was
never president she was never president
but she might classified documents and
she was still a public official and
that's what they're saying is the
presidential thing is out of it because
he's out of office and that so now
they're saying is Hillary Clinton had
classified documents so if you're going
to deal equally and I'm just a big due
process guy if you're going to give due
process you should have equal treatment
so the doj should at least have gotten a
an opinion from the doj lawyers all
right why didn't Merrick Garland get an
opinion for you guys are going way into
Special Report land hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else